okay so this is my favorite part he
really up in my opinion he really
gives away the whole game here you guys
are on a month-to-month contract with us
and you guys could have walked at any
point
saw this occurrence and it's being you
know you've been rolling
you're like you're like a pumpkin
what are you saying we were just
cracking up because we're like did you
really just say that I mean he's blaming
us for trusting that right bro why if
you knew that we were stealing from you
why didn't you leave sooner yes we
robbed you but it's your fault for not
checking yourself you didn't notice that
we were robbing you we didn't tell you
we were robbing you it's your fault for
trusting us don't you know we're all
scumbag shame on you and he's right
essentially he is right but I don't
think he's supposed to say that out loud
like I said there was an unfortunate
situation with our last head of Finance
where she was supposed to check this and
she didn't so he is right you know he's
like listen we exist to steal as much
money from you as possible if you didn't
notice that that's on you in my opinion